[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame monsieur bonsoir Le Mur de Berlin
le mur de toutes les émotions après
avoir été durant 28 ans le mur de toutes
les hontes nous sommes ici à Berlin ne
parlons plus de Berlin Ouest ne parlons
plus de Berlin est nous sommes ici à
Checkpoint Charlie cette frédriich
strass par laquelle les étrangers
seulement pénétraient à Berlin Est et
maintenant ce ne sont plus les étrangers
ce sont les Allemands les Allemands de
l'Est de l'Ouest qui peuvent franchir
cette frontière comme toutes les
frontières entre les deux Allemagnes
événement donc majeur un événement qui a
bouleversé Berlin Ouest aujourd'hui
400000 Berlinois de l'Est sont venus
passer ce samedi de l'autre côté
respirer un autre air celui de l'Ouest
celui de la liberté pour eux ils ont
ouvert de très grands yeux ils ont reçu
100 dollars chacun lorsqu'ils sont
arrivés pour la première fois à l'ouest
et puis ils ont passé la journée auprès
de leurs frères et de leurs sœurs
d'Allemagne fédérale du moins de Berlin
Ouest Hélène Risacher et ambroisperérin
sont allés encore tout à l'heure dans le
centre ville de Berlin Ouest près de du
quartier du zoau et de la grande gare et
vous allez suivre toute la journée de
solidarité entre allemand de l'Est et
allemand de l'Ouest tandis que les
passages ici à Checkpoint Charlie se
succèdent encore et se prolongeront très
tard dans la
[Applaudissements]
nuit weekend à Berlin wouest ils sont
300000 peut-être plus venu de l'Est une
foule énorme qui envahi le centrreeville
ce soir fermé à la circulation pour
accueillir ceux de l'Est les Allemands
de l'Ouest ont laissé leur place dans
les restaurants les cafés et la rue une
réelle
solidarité non ce n'est pas grave qu'il
y ait autant de monde la ville est
grande je sais que des centaines de gens
ici ont téléphoné pour dire qu'ils
étaient prêts à accueillir chez eux les
Allemands de l'Est qui veulent rester là
cette
nuit mais pour les Berlinois non
allemands l'invasion de l'Est paraî à
terre plus
risqué je crois moi que c'est très bien
que ce soit libre ici mais j'ai peur
qu'on ait des problèmes parce qu'ici
vous voyez il y a beaucoup de monde ils
sont là ils traînent ils ont besoin
d'argent et c'est un
problème vous savez tous les gens qui
sont ici à l'ouest pensent que les
impôts pourraient
augmenter mais les Allemands de l'Ouest
continuent de recevoir avec chaleur leur
voisin de RDA à la banque les allemand
l'est reçoivent chacun sans marque sur
présentation de leur passeport et au
post-fontières la bienvenue leur est
souhaitée bénévolement avec bonbons et
chocolat voilà donc s marque et quantité
d'autres marques d'attention de la part
des Allemands de l'Ouest pour leurs
frères leurs voisins donc Berlinois de
l'Est et Allemands de l'Est en général
le mur n'existe pratiquement plus c'est
devenu une passoire d'autres ouvertures
vont se produire d'ici quelques jours et
mardi prochain il y aura plus d'une
vingtaine de points de passage entre les
les deux Berlins le mur c'est tout de
même encore le lieu de rassemblement de
toutes les les émotions on l'a vu avec
rostropovic ce midi et ce mur de Berlin
et bien nous allons y revenir la nuit
dernière qui était la deuxième nuit de
folie de folie douce je dirais sur ce
mur de Berlin hlè Risacher en brisperin
ont vécu cette nuit sur le
mur ils ont réussi quelques heures après
avoir commencé à piocher emble les
jeunes Allemands de l'Est et de l'Ouest
ont percé les premières ouvertures sur
l'autre côté en RDA jour et nuit le mur
de Berlin devient l'attraction numéro 1
sur la quasi-ttalité de ces 173 km de
long à la porte de brandbourg ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux le nouveau jeu
consiste à se laisser glisser du côté
Est pour narguer les forces de l'ordre
de RDA chargé d'empêcher les
débordements lorsque la tension monte la
police charge ou fait donner le canon à
haut et les manifestants crient laisser
le peuple libre pas de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
violence depuis quelques heures le mur
ressemble à un Woodstock un peu
surréaliste on bois on danse et on vient
de partout voir l'histoire en
[Applaudissements]
marche ça c'est inimaginable depuis que
ce mur est construit moi je pensais que
jamais je ne vivrai ça
moi je filme parce que ce moment est
unique et je pourrais le montrer plus
tard à mes amis et à mes
[Musique]
enfants c'est mie rien c'est seulement
joue je crois depuis 24 28 ans et c'est
nul ouais je crois ce truc n'existe pas
dans à peu près de semaines ou quelque
chose comme
ça nous allons pour un instant quitter
cet aspect émotionnel des choses et
parler de l'avenir parler de de la de la
politique de peut-être de la
réunification de l'Allemagne ce n'est
pas encore tout à fait d'actualité en
tous les cas elmou Cole le chancelier
fédéral aujourd'hui a réuni son cabinet
à bonne et il a également beaucoup
téléphoné il a téléphoné à
Egon Kens le numéro 1 d'Allemagne de
l'Est pour souhaiter tous les deux se
réunir bientôt il a aussi beaucoup
téléphoné à ses partenaires européens
tandis que les cris ici continuent de
retentir ici à Checkpoint Charlie donc
monsieur elmouco a beaucoup téléphoné à
ses collègues européens et notamment à
François miteran pour qu'il soit
beaucoup coup questions de l'Allemagne
de l'Est lors du prochain sommet
européen début décembre à Strasbourg
Gill dujonchet nous dit aujourd'hui ce
qui s'est passé au niveau politique en
Allemagne
fédérale c'est le chancelier qui a
proposé la tenue de ce sommet
interallemand chez nous avant Noël à
déclaré on Kens monsieur co l'a formulé
dans notre conversation téléphonique ce
matin en même temps qu'il saluait les
dispositions que nous avons prises en
matière de liberté de circulation même
si le numéro 1 est allemand a souligné à
cette occasion qu'il était hors de
question de supprimer l'existence des
deux États allemands l'annonce de ce
prochain sommet est le premier signe
d'un rapprochement politique entre les
deux dirigeants le deuxième était le
Conseil des ministres extraordinaires
qui s'est réuni ce matin à bonne
consacré aux mesures spéciales à prendre
à la suite de l'ouverture des frontières
interallemande il a aussi évoqué la
possibilité d'une aide économique à la
RDA l'Allemagne de l'Est a besoin de nos
investissement pour que ses habitants
soient incités à rester plutôt que de
passer massivement en RFA a expliqué le
chancelier un peu plus tard lors d'une
conférence de presse helmou Cole y met
certes des conditions qu'il a précisé la
tenue des élections libres promises par
le PC est allemand et aussi le passage
d'une économie planifiée à une économie
de marché en RDA mais c'est clair les
priorités du gouvernement ouest allemand
sont désormais plus qu'avant tourné vers
l'Allemagne de l'Est le chancelier a
d'ailleurs révélé qu'il avait téléphoné
aujourd'hui au président mitteran et
proposer que la question allemande soit
le thème central du prochain Conseil
européen de décembre à Strasbourg il ne
l'a pas dit mais il est en effet que les
12 se penchent ensemble sur ce problème
plutôt que de n'être évoqué que par les
deux supergr en Méditerranée les 2 et 3
décembre les Allemands de l'Est comment
réagissent-ils à cette situation toute
nouvelle pour eux mais mona interman est
allé cet après-midi interroger quelques
Allemands de l'Est qui s'apprêtaient à
partir pour l'Ouest ou qui restaient
tout de même il en restait un peu
d'Allemands de de l'est aujourd'hui à
Berlin Est écoutez les réactions de ces
Allemands de l'Est à la situation
actuelle et à la personnalité à l'action
de monsieuron
K 10h ce matin c'est déjà la foule
friich STR côté Berlin est beaucoup nous
disent que c'est leur tout premier
voyage à l'ouest et ils sont
reconnaissant àon d'avoir ouvert le mur
mais ce geste du numéro 1 de la RDA ne
suffit pas dis pour nous séduire il faut
des gages plus tangibles pour une vraie
démocratie
durable nous voulons des réformes avec
de vraies élections libres et puis le
respect de la volonté des gens
je ne fais pas confiance
à les choses vont beaucoup trop
vite trop de g de l'an équipeoujours
placeiis Guer en France aujourd'hui
croire éta l'homme de la police
d'État alors changer comme
ça la liberté c'est
quoi qu'estce que
c'est vous voulez aller à l'ouest
non ces de ne sont pas encore all à
l'ouest malgré le accoutrement il disent
qu'il n' pas du tout la nostalgie d'unee
épo il faut pasire une seule allemag
expliqu a trop montré que c'était
dangereux il faut deux états avec une
identité différente mais la liberté pour
tous le soir tombe à l'Ouest était un
aller-retour au point de passage de Val
des centaines d'Allemands rentrent dans
les sarcs des trésors introuvables de ce
côté-ci des bananes et des
yaourts aujourd'hui il est difficile de
dire si cette liberté octroyée par le
régime va réduire le flux des
réfugiés voici donc pour les réactions
des Allemands de l'Est de la rue je
dirais aujourd'hi recueilli par Mona
interman mais mona est également allé
devant le siège du Parlement de RDA en
effet c'est là que tout va se décider
dans les jours prochains et c'est là que
le Parti communiste va tenter de sauver
sa peau sans doute sous la conduite de
Monsieur Egon krens Mona a rencontré
également vous l'entendrez une membre du
Parti communiste de RDA le SED